resumes Jennifer what are you doing a
daddy thing
look at this 360 360 720 baby look at
that
look nailed it
[Music]
life hack - it's your toothbrush not
good enough
just grab your nearest vibrator tape it
together with your toothbrush carefully
great now enjoy your vibrating tooth
brush your teeth will thank you oh yeah
this is a good place
what's the name again my a police state
stay close I got another paratus oh I
just have to survive no no
[Music]
oh god it's one of those [ __ ] hey
girl you're like my pants I don't know
what I'm doing Oh God two is missing now
we're we're gonna cross the street are
you [ __ ] kidding me
how am I supposed to do that did you see
how many cars there are all right here
we go all right so let's get rid of his
arms then all right yeah
dammit dammit dammit alright you know
what [ __ ] you we're halfway there Bruce
our pugs are still intact
[Music]
get it end end end end hurts me plenty
my queen God thank you for Christmas so
this is basically like Russian relay
where the balloon will pop with one of
these it's like a bullet I know how a
gun works I'm a man
[Music]
hello Teddy
let's make some tea shall we yes now
where's my rocket launcher there it is
all right let's take this Nazi scam ah
[ __ ]
Oh headshot hey he's soaked away though
look at him Hey
hi oh god no that's not care way not
care way what are you like when I touch
you teddy would you like me to finger
you Teddy this is how we did sweet
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh God Oh came up with this [ __ ]
literally it's actually a soap oh did
you see that did you see that that's
amazing
help her recover from this accident and
make her look beautiful again
now holla holla holla holla are you
saying BAE it sound beautiful [ __ ] you
Barbie
you look fabulous I don't understand the
problem
[Music]
oh my it's just a really hard to blow up
what
may I say that's quite a beautiful baby
you have they would be shame if anything
happened Mario centipede yeah oh my god
I got a high fly myself a catch I'm to
retire I'm too stupid wait it's it's
simple I didn't [ __ ] look that's why
hey Luigi mummy I think possible if I
fail now I will cry the tears of a
million oh if I'm ready
can I really kill another one of my self
noobs
teach me some pie how to get a lots of
subs
[Music]
I'll forego embrace this beer to pack
hope you enjoyed that montage remember
to always leave a comment hit that like
button to show you support and share
with all your non existing friends last
montage we did we had 30 something
million bros now we're at 34 million
bros which means we're bigger than
Canada here's a map of all the countries
we've dominated thank you bros for
always being there and for always being
a bro world domination it's near but for
now stay awesome bros it comes to broke
[ __ ]
[Music]